hello there and welcome to PlayStation
granade Resident Evil 2 remake without a
doubt was my game of the year in 2019
now in 2020 resident evil 3 nemesis is
here to take everything we learned from
Claire and Leon journey and turn it up
to 11 here's everything you need to know
before buying resident evil 3 nemesis
[Music]
[Applause]
here's a quick overview Resident Evil
three takes place before and after
Resident Evil 2
yes strange Jill Valentine returns as
our hero after surviving the original
mansion incident which set all this in
motion as this happens before re 2
begins we will see the panic spread
through the streets we will see much
more of the city and hopefully encounter
more of the living before the zombie
hordes take over our e3 nemesis isn't
for the faint-hearted
gore and horror by the bucketload expect
to be tense expect jump scares expect
survival mechanics but here is where we
encounter the first real change from
Resident Evil 2 remake where Leon and
Claire struggle to locate weapons and
ammo Capcom have confirmed resident evil
3 nemesis will have a shift in focus
becoming more about action and fighting
the outbreak aggressively don't take
this as a sign that old habits are being
repeated as they will remain a focus on
survival but in this story we've come to
fight take a look at some of the weapons
on offer and the sheer amount of ammo
being used in these gunfights action
returns to Resident Evil for better or
for worse I'm not sure oh and we can off
the undead with contextual kills like a
good old bright red barrel you've
guessed it it goes boom one mechanic
which fundamentally changes the way the
game feels is a new dodge motion
Jill can actively avoid lunges from
enemies
she's a star's team member and therefore
a step up from rookie cop early on her
skill set reflects this she can avoid
incoming damage we get this should Jill
dodge perfectly she'll have a brief
moment of slow motion to hit some
critical headshots our own speed and
reactions and ultimately our timing will
be rewarded in resident evil 3 nemesis a
nice touch back in 1999 the original
game was surprisingly short for a
full-fledged number in the series this
time around that has been fixed the
story of resident evil 3 nemesis will be
expanded massively the areas visited for
mere moments in the OG game will now
play a bigger part in all affairs and to
go with that all dialogue has been
evolved and expanded - to modernize the
entire piece things like the tram that
the trolley system segment now
place on a train system it may be a
small change but the game will feel as
if it happened in this timeline much
more updated same with the dialogue if
you check out the scene of Nicolai in
the subway his character has been
fleshed out immensely so without jumping
to too many conclusions expect
everything from the 90s evolved and
expanded for a 2020 audience in a world
where games are remade so often it can
be difficult to understand why we play
the same story again 20 years later well
in our e3 nemesis changes have been made
it's the same but it's different let me
explain a little all the same story
beats are in the game from the ps1 days
but they have been changed or delayed or
remixed to keep us on our toes for
example when you'd expect a certain boss
fight to happen the game will subvert
your expectations and move the boss
fight to another part of the game
this keeps everyone on their toes
including the hardcore fans and
hopefully will give them a scare or two
we all know that horror survival games
are renowned for their difficulty this
is not the case with our e3 nemesis due
to adaptive difficulty mechanics this
will make us our own best friend and
worst enemy simply put if we struggle
with encounters the game will understand
and notice these and slightly change
things
maybe making a boss fight a little
easier or adding additional ammo or
healing items around the location to
help you out more here's the thing to
remember adaptive difficulty works both
ways the better players will be pushed
to breaking point with more enemies to
fight less ammo around and more
aggressive zombies however you play the
game we'll make notes and adapt the
experience accordingly let's get the
elephant in the room addressed as the
name suggests resident evil 3 nemesis is
all about the Nemesis a hulking great
biological weapon with a single task in
life to hunt down and kill the last
remaining stars team members and you
know it Jill is the top of that list
well her and Brad but Brad's I've got a
bad feeling about Brad's the Nemesis
will pursue us throughout the entire
game he'll be everywhere from the
streets to the rooftops and get this he
can even enter safe rooms yes Resident
Evil is renowned for safe rooms giving
us that warm and cozy feeling that we
can't
hurt well not anymore the nemesis will
be invading your space at every
opportunity and if you're thinking that
nemi is another mr. X from Resident Evil
2 think again we've been told nemesis
will make re - tyrant feel like an
annoying neighbor compared to this freak
of science let's - confirmed playable
characters in Resident Evil 3 but I
wouldn't be surprised if more are hidden
away until release day Jill we've talked
about the badass stars team member and
Carlos a member of youcbs
umbrella biohazard countermeasure
service so yeah the bad guys in the
story have a unit designed to look like
the heroes of the piece Kellogg's and
his squad mates are here to rescue
civilians in the aftermath of the
outbreak in Raccoon City once again as
Kalos is a military corporal he will
have access to even more weaponry and if
you're a fan of the game in 1999 Carlos
sees playable sections have been
expanded and opened up his character has
been developed further oh and his
character has changed here's a nod to
the 90s do you remember Carlos back then
he was bit of a greasy ladies man which
was nice but now he seems more
well-rounded if I'm honest I quite liked
sleazy Carlos another key difference -
luscious game is the inclusion of more
of the undead on screen at once thinking
back to last year I think I had about 4
zombies on screen well in resident evil
3 nemesis the ante is being up to gain
hordes of the undead line the streets
and meander as a group we'll have to
manage how we take these out - a waste
our ammunition or do we look for these
environmental kills all this adds an
extra layer of tactical knowledge to the
proceedings Capcom have adapted their
inventory system for this outing - it's
not my blowing but it's a subtle change
you should notice upon picking up an
item in re to remake we'd be transported
to the inventory screen this worked well
for a slow-paced horror vibe but in our
e3 nemesis this is no longer the case
anything we pick up will be
automatically placed in our backpack and
given a spot in our inventory elements
will stack automatically - it looks like
due to the amount of ammo we'll be
picking up this change was inevitable to
keep the game moving forward no more
jumping to our inventory screen
unwillingly one of the greatest reasons
to replay the original are e3 nemesis
was the endings there weren't many but
interactions in the game led to
different outcomes it was it was great
suddenly the call has been made there
will only be one single ending in the
2020 version of our e3 nemesis one which
will tie up all loose ends I'm told so
if you've waited 20 years to know which
of the endings in our e3 is the correct
one your wait is over we will know what
is canon soon enough if you're on the
fence about buying this one you should
try the demo releasing on march 19th
you'll be able to play a small segment
of the game as Jill Valentine explore
the city and try out the new mechanics
in the game you may even find a heap of
easter eggs - and in fact another reason
to jump into the demo is to find the
bobbleheads
here in our e3 the mr. Charlie
bobbleheads are hiding around the demo
there's 20 to find and they act like the
raccoons in last year's Resident Evil
game they may unlock something in the
full game so I'll be back later in the
week with all the locations for you
there's another part of Resident Evil 3
this time around
sadly the Merc mode has been removed
which is a bit of a bummer but look
what's here instead our e3 Nemesis comes
bundled with a multiplayer game named
resistance an isometric survivors versus
a single mastermind if you've played
games like dead by daylight or my
personal favorite would be Friday the
13th you'll know what to expect here for
human survivors are tasked with escaping
a facility each of these characters has
a different skillset and abilities on
the other side is a single mastermind
setting up traps to kill the test
subjects and one other thing they can do
is call in a tyrant and take control of
it I'm super hyped for this one please
are my discard if this is your kind of
game I'm looking for people to play with
re fans should know that this isn't
canon though so there's no story to be
gained here but on the plus side we can
play as random characters from the re
universe including Annette Birkin from
re - and Alex Spencer amongst others and
released the very moment I'm saying this
there will be an open beta for everyone
to try out the new mode on March 27th
market in your calendars and one week
before the game comes out for real let's
go over some of the collectables and
different versions of the game there
isn't that many this year compared to
last
Resident Evil games always come with a
killer collectible and our e3 nemesis is
no different this time the collectible
Edition includes a figurine of Jill
Valentine 11 inches of Beauty tough to
turn down for hardcore fans there's the
good old art book here too and the og
soundtrack from 1999 Oh in the case the
case is lenticular which means it has
frames of movement when you move your
hand slightly when holding it it's
pretty cool it's a nice touch the
collector's edition also has a Raccoon
City map there's an edition in between
the collector's and standard edition in
which you will receive an umbrella
keyring and the Stars police Bunch
you should check what's available in
your country as sometimes things are
regional and of course expect themes to
be included in digital variations of the
game and if you preorder early enough
you will get access to retro skins so
Jill wearing that little tube top
perfect for the zombie apocalypse so
when can we get our hands on the full
final release April the 3rd it's so
close I'm so hyped for this one are you
grabbing our e3 nemesis by the way if
you've stayed this long please write
stars in the comments and I'll find you
and give you a heart thanks for your
time it's much appreciated I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade I'll see you in
Raccoon City
[Music]